when Mayor Ed Koch took office in 1978
New York City was crumbling the South
Bronx once a thriving middle class
neighborhood had become a national
symbol of urban decline and devastation
crime rates soared out of control
spending and brought the city to the
brink of bankruptcy leading to a state
takeover of its finances the subway like
much of the city's infrastructure was
literally and figuratively running off
the rails period films such as death
wish the Warriors and Escape from New
York captured the prevailing sense that
lawlessness and disorder would
ultimately destroy America's biggest
city on July 13th 1977 the city reached
its nadir when a 24-hour blackout gave
way to mass looting Bushwick a
working-class neighborhood in Brooklyn
was burned to the ground what do you
think that the city should have done for
you the other they should have stopped
them for coming in they were standing
here and they won't do anything then New
York City Mayor a beam a former
accountant and longtime Democratic Party
apparatchik struggle to maintain control
know what the cop said to me why should
I miss my life for you what did you do
for us
[Music]
then came Edward Irving Koch
[Music]
rush to the phone
the alert says touch
[Music]
Oh Koch's hutzpah was exactly what the
city needed I have a right to disagree
with it I'd like to know did I lose my
First Amendment rights because I became
when they arise if I disagree with
someone no but on to the cases she would
she would show what a self-proclaimed
liberal with sanity Koch took on special
interest
he put the city's finances back in order
and he showed that it was not only
possible to govern but to have fun doing
it it's all part of being mayor the
secret is to enjoy it Koch loves the
media famously taking questions from
reporters in the City Hall bathroom and
there was virtually no topic on which he
wouldn't venture an oversized opinion
singing dance
he can also balance the budget he'll
hire he gained a national reputation by
being the quintessential New Yorker a
Bronx born ethnic whose disparaging
remarks about life outside the city may
well have cost him a bid for the
governor's mansion in Albany long
presumed to be gay
Koch kept mum about his personal life
since losing his bid for a fourth term
in 1989 Koch has been a tireless
dilettante he's written books and hosted
his own radio show he was judged waspers
first replacement on the People's Court
he made a total mess step by step did
you put holes in the window yeah I paid
for the broken window he started a
non-profit to clean up corruption in the
state capital he turned his passion for
film into an a vocation as a movie
review now on the YouTube channel the
mayor at the movie what do you think I'm
going to do it's a plus
earlier this year New York's Queensboro
Bridge was renamed in his honor i sat
down with Mayor Koch at his office in
Midtown in April of 2011 1977 you ran
for mayor of New York as a liberal with
sanity who had the fiscal crisis which
was huge in looming crime was spiraling
out of control there was a perception
that New York was a nun Governor Bull
City what was your role in addressing
those kinds of issues well when people
said new
arc City was uncover malai said it
depends on who's governing it and I
quickly established that I would be in
charge the commitment that I made was
that no matter how unpopular I would
become as a result of taking the
measures to reduce the expenditures so
that we ultimately would have a balanced
budget
meaning not spending more money than we
were taking in that I would take and
what I said was you know if you all who
I've somehow or other injured in the
sense that we're talking about got
together you could throw me out and if
you do I'll get a better job and you
won't get a better mayor well how
important was that you know that your
force of personality how important was
that to your success Pat Moynihan son
Pat Moynihan phrased it I gave the
people back their morale you had to get
people to follow you and I'm I think
reticent personality quite private but I
realized that would not do the job and
so I became far more on stage to the
point where I recall saying if you
follow me I will lead you across the
desert that's pretty nutty statement but
I meant it what was the biggest
expenditure that you cut or what would
what was that because I can't look at it
that way you have to look at it at it as
for example the police went down from
26,000 to 22,000 we had to cut almost
every program my recollection is we used
to say there about 50 agencies they all
have to be cut but not equally so it's
not across the board ten percent and we
did it in the state of New York gave us
four years within which to accomplish
that and we did it in three years what
do you think the role of rent control
was in the wind lling of New York's
housing special did not it was not
responsible for the reduction in housing
I mean the landlord's would say that
rent controls were necessary are
necessary today they
cover of the three million apartments in
New York City about 1 million apartments
and it keeps the middle class does it
actually end up rewarding people who are
well-connected I mean you famous they
didn't think lived in a rent control
apartment I was mayor I had a
rent-controlled apartment then I went to
Gracie Mansion where the city provides
accommodations I kept my apartment at
that time I no longer have it did I need
it I mean could I pay the market rent
sure shouldn't you have been I mean no
if it's a rent control just like a wife
all the procedure for rent control
departments had nothing to do with the
tenants it had to do with the apartment
was rent controlled it wasn't that the
tenant was very controlled with
Bloomberg and Giuliani as well one of
the things that they're criticized for
is getting rid of a lot of the rough
edges of New York you know you can't
smoke in you can't smoke in cities you I
we can't have trans fat here calorie
counts are on the menus things like
that's wrong what do well I'm job asking
like do my thing I think that the
government can enter these areas
delicately if you will I mean not with a
saber type Fiat but in the responsible y
Limburg talked about waging a war on
salt is that a legitimate function I
mean it's an education war I don't know
what the statistics are but I suspect
that a huge percentage of people in
America including those in New York are
suffering from obesity children in
particular and from diabetes would you
have been a better governor than Mario
Cuomo I'm not going to
say that at all I think that Mario Cuomo
was a good governor I think I would have
been a good governor who do you like
what Andrew Cuomo was doing so andrew
has been spectacular in his successes in
reducing budgetary deficit by ten
billion dollars
it's those hundred and thirty three
billion dollar budget though so it's
does that have the cushion change it's
incredible now but Andrew Cuomo has also
pushed the idea that he is going to
reduce expenditures without raising
taxes and he says that's very important
to maintain any vitality do you and
Mario Cuomo were political rivals there
were ugly scenes both when you were both
running for mayor as well as governor
but and Andrew Cuomo it's ascribed to
him that he came up with a couple of the
but you know some of the ugliest
sloganeering in American politics vote
for Cuomo not the home oh don't be a
[ __ ] things like that what was the
role of your Perseus Lee Andrew Cuomo
denies it and I accept the fact that he
did not do that but that someone in
their campaign did are we in a better
place in America where those types of
charges don't carry the same weight now
and I don't know how to bury the same
way I don't know that I don't but I mean
clearly America compared to 1977 or 1982
is far more accepting of of any possible
lifestyle
would you agree no I would it's more
accepting but it's not accepting so for
example in the New York one of the
progressive states and the Union most
progressive there was legislation before
the state Senate last year on allowing
same-sex marriage and it went down to a
terrible defeat what is the role of
public figures particularly politicians
in creating broader social tolerance and
very much would suffice I believe that's
what leadership is all about are you gay
now will tell you that's a very
interesting question I refuse to answer
that question because if I answered your
question
how then would you prevent every
political organization in America when
it rates candidates and sends
questionnaires is to put in the question
what's your sexual orientation do you
think that that was that should be
permissible I don't think so well but
people I mean people notice what I'm
saying yeah no no and I I don't work
question legitimatize is a political
organization asking that of every single
candidate but doesn't it also lose its
power if people say yeah you know what
I'm gay or a heterosexual or I mean it
open man would you I've asked you the
question would you allow by affirming
that the legitimacy of every organ
political organization asking every
candidate running for office that
question would you allow that I would I
think that everybody has the right to
ask whatever question that allowing a
stench of affirm you know and I would I
would if I was running for office I
would answer questions like that to not
rob them if you do you believe that
well let me that's about toilet do you
believe that the Sierra Club and asking
rather all of the questions a good
government organization I think it Elsa
should have the legitimate right we're
not talking about the right
legitimate right to ask every candidate
what is your sexual orientation why
would that be different than saying do
you recycle at home
I mean it's oriented my question yeah
actually I think they I dunno I dunno
and and but I also because I think you
know those lifestyle issues should not
should not matter in people's uh whether
they should or they shouldn't there a
certain areas of privacy you fought in
World War two which is something that is
rarely remarked upon in your public
record what's your strongest memory from
fighting having a friend blown up in a
he's lying in a foxhole and the more
made a direct hit there's nothing left
that's my strongest memory in terms of
your congressional career
what are your high points this is also
something that rarely gets discussed but
you were you were elected for four terms
only nice five charms some of the
highlights well I am very proud of the
fact that with Bella Abzug and two other
members of Congress we introduced in
1974 legislation that would a bar
discrimination based on sexual
orientation this is 74 aside from two
other members four of us altogether no
other member of Congress would become a
co-sponsor I'm very proud of that
let's go through a kind of lightning
round of current people and just give me
your quick response this is kind of a
Rorschach test Donald Trump he's a
bracket and probably is the best
huckster in America and has taken the
press for a ride on his presidential
campaign New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie superb person who started what
governors now are doing all over the
nation which is acknowledging that you
don't spend money you don't have do you
like his engagement with the teachers
unions unless I am one of those people
who believe that Mayor Bloomberg and
other mayor's around the country and
governors who have taken on the teachers
union have done a very important job
they are no longer able to sell what
they used to be able to sell which is
all they're interested in the teachers
is the children people understand today
that their major interest is their
salaries and their pensions the Tea
Party well I think it's a collection of
diverse people nuts in it
we've seen them they
they run for office but there are others
who identify on the basis that they
think the federal government's out of
control and they would like to reduce
the government they're not bad people in
that sense and that's not a philosophy
that is terrible what do you think about
the Internet
I'm not computer literate I have two
secretaries that are absolutely
spectacular but you are a youtube
sensation with the mayor at the movies
yeah because I have people who do the
technology I do the thinking George W
Bush how do you rate his presidency I
think we're marvelous on standing up to
terrorism and I said when I endorsed him
I didn't agree with him on a single
domestic issue
what about Barack Obama I think he it's
not a lousy job on Foreign Relations
that's my commentary I think he
displayed a hostility to Israel that is
very wrong I think that what is his
hostility to Israel well I think he
believes that Israel is the impediment
to good relations with the Arab world
he's wrong
as we see today every Arab country is
having a revolution whether it's good
revolution or bad revolution I don't
know because we don't know what these
people who are in the streets really
want but I believe that President Obama
when he made his speech in Egypt did not
ever go to Israel which all prior
presidents have done especially if they
went to Egypt first thing toward Israel
second or vice-versa and so he's not
trusted by supporters of Israel not just
you sue I'm Jewish
but there are more Christians supporting
Israel than there are Jews thank God
what are the lessons from New York I
mean you you have lived an immense you
know an immensely rich life I mean I
have growing up in being born in 1924
world war two living through the
depression World War two you were lucky
enough to spend some time living in New
Jersey the greatest state in the Union
scape from newer 0:17 you know you came
through some of the roughest is the
Jessica score book and I are very good
friends well I wanted to get what is
what can New York and what can New York
City what can it teach the rest of the
country you know I really can't improve
on the statement of song you can make it
here you can make it anywhere there's a
certain street smarts so there's a
certain New York humor there's a we're
not smarter than the rest of the country
we are the rest of the country less than
50% of the people who live in the city
of New York were born here I'm one of
them
I was born in the Bronx but the rest
came from every state in the Union and
every country in the world so we are
America Ed Koch thank you very much for
talking to reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]